[Music]
well guys it's that time of year again
love is in the air and you don't want to
be playing soloqueue tonight if you
catch my drift now around this time last
year we gave you the top 10 hottest guys
in csgo and the year before that it was
the top 10 hottest guys in the league of
legends and this year we're not doing
DOTA sorry but our Valentine's Day gift
to you is the top 10 sexiest plays in
eSports now a little caveat before we
get started in this video we're talking
about types of plays here so keep that
in mind before you flame us in the
comment section now on with the video
guys we're starting this list off with a
play that every FPS player aspires to
pull off in a match the one tab then
TOCOM of my length ups the beautiful man
on screen aside I think we can all agree
that one tabs are just plain sex he's
got one foot in it he's one bullet just
knows on purpose scream makes me scream
they're quick they're efficient and they
get better with age
[Music]
but you know what's sexier than landing
a one tap hitting more than one cat
somebody pecan envious side head well
that's what happens when you go around
the corner happy with few things are
sexier than finding a partner that looks
to bring out the best in you someone who
puts their own needs secondary to yours
and can help you flourish in
high-pressure situations which is why
these selfless play comes in at number
nine on our list
hi Tom to talk to never do be Saudi Anna
Anna Chinese do it here he's in our
mouth shut
oh this lifetime well let's see reckless
azan myth the amazing Zhaan honey where
can Reckless Getaway he's been stand-up
meals it's gonna be able to get one soon
save reckless his life and despite being
mostly in the shadows these players set
up their stars for success which is in
its own right and it looks like for the
role to protect him time still coming
out Louis to look into going beneath the
people vital one more in boxes over bike
right but ultimate might save Josh he
actually carried them through the legs
down low are you kidding me
quality is good but sometimes quantity
is better and these sugar daddies are
bringing home the bacon with an absolute
arm full of kills in our number eight
entry here he comes once again the first
base is it renny's gonna hit the ground
there's cold
how does he do this he comes the ice
blocks ready
[Applause]
here's the chump it is a to meadow
thicket of bulls stinky is that there's
a turret alignment they gonna be careful
a big knock Megadeth the killer the
Borgata this year goes down as well but
the Ducks are coming through a double
Guilford balls when you're outnumbered
there's only one thing to do that's take
them all down by yourself and after all
there's nothing like someone who could
perform when the lights are on and
everyone's watching spark gets pushed on
he is very wisely not getting image so
bright get the triple kill
sookay want me to be in trouble lotta
damage goes every shilling up so quickly
Casas in trouble
ooh be looking for the I just look for
two he's feeling himself
[Applause]
it's not about hitting everyone it's
about hitting the perfect spot which is
why the skill-shot lands at number 7 on
our list we're taking a look at the
plays that put the skill back into
skill-shot now Rick you look on the
retreat ever been looking for them ever
move not able to find it on everybody is
there though oh the banish my family
gentlemen as well
do you get to be that good but with the
voice off from God and when it comes to
the finale it's all about landing the
big money shot potential but they do
have Paco Baker can get a kill this
early that's gonna be great
the troops fine days is available it's
now at two versus four flash it's in so
much trouble
concussive blows gets a petrifying gaze
that's just gonna delay the inevitable
Brown goes down all right let's face it
if you're aiming to please you've got to
be good with your hands
which is why pulling off a sick micro
play comes in at number six after all
nothing gets the fans riled up more than
commanding a flock of muta lists or a
carpet of Sighs storms
[Music]
[Applause]
and who doesn't love a good meatball
play trying to push out and rat out that
coupling but have to say a lot of socks
important
when it comes down to micro it's not
just about how fast you can go it's
about finesse and attention to detail I
know some a micro man this micro
obviously really really good what we're
seeing here in splitting starts and
sibelius oh my god he's so good when it
comes to fighting games there's just
nothing sexier than seeing a hard read
payoff which is why the parry comes in
at number five on our list I see you
infiltration I know what you're gonna do
there's the parry there's my win it's a
catch both of the baby bear is it
the reversal coming out so he got the
memory up a bit
predicting your opponent and reacting
accordingly is a slick move that
displays confidence a keen mind and a
good sense of rhythm
everybody wants the reset you can hear
the crowd coming in you want to get
close Oh Mary Mary I just you whip that
jab in the middle to get the timing Wow
this man is ready and let's not forget
Daigo who pulled off the sexiest play in
fighting game history
[Applause]
we've shown off a lot of mechanically
intensive plays on this list but being
sexy is not all about being flashy
sometimes it's about staying calm cool
and collected no matter how hot and
heavy the situation gets which is why
pulling off a clutch comes in at number
four Guardian reveals that he's coming
from I mean low HP easy but most
importantly it's about consistently
performing when the pressure is on
that's fine why not leave him out of
this the Big Apple and snacks is hungry
he's got one kill already on the USP low
HP as well on Guardian and flame he's
trying to beat them out trying to get
the middle one on long as he dances back
and forth between
it's quite a ways away Moringa prone
with the shotgun blast can't go around
the corner catch Oh
the madman silencing the crowd the Mira
playing inside of small office he'll go
for a c4 tosses it out go ahead BC that
sets the lift for two seconds can take
you fight him no evil geniuses will
stick the third
[Applause]
love is a two-player game and this
valentine's day we hope you don't find
yourself alone even if it is in a 1v1 to
the death after all nothing says
confidence like styling on your opponent
mano-a-mano for everyone to see Baker
may be a trouble your death Bart tries
to clean it up for real oh look at the
class look at the bows thank you
why was that restful again though
Stratus can tell she quick of tornado
and P combo someone makes you come
across and how best ball has s for just
getting so located by chops in nitro
does have a lot of another smoke so it
could be really rough for several times
to get through this he's gonna throw the
AWP and they chase EDG all the way back
is he gonna try and go huge it
and make it three Nabi taking the
runner-up spot on our list is one of
these sexiest ways you can kill your
opponent the flick oh my Jesus dude what
is that Jesus Christ that's Jason Bourne
whether it's an elegant swipe of the arm
or a filthy flick of the wrist these
plays are the eSports embodiment of
timeless beauty ninjas in his face very
soon oh that's is fast and nailed the
shots not many widow-makers would go for
this play but I'd would he just
absolutely nails it here even if she got
one up on the party Pournami gotta give
it scary but that Guardian has something
to say about that takes out the kill on
a margin
but flicks aren't just shallow eye candy
they showcase a level of raw skill that
even the most jaded eSports fan can
appreciate Karen is gonna be waiting he
co charges in and now both Moe's back
with the ankle there this should be
impossible from the way that's a nice
flick though but still with the
10-second he's gotta find Hobbit off to
the left Oh what is that flick for
Dracon what the hell did we just see he
has no idea what just happened either
lands the first shot he's fully aware
I'm both frightened and the roast for
some a person's sexiest feature might be
their eyes for others it might be their
body but for us it's the brain and
that's why we think that pulling off a
200 IQ play is the sexiest thing you can
do in eSports don't believe us well
we'll let the X God Himself show you
what we mean gambit has sent even more
firepower that's bring more hope it's
huge Georgie's thrown into the corner
get blamed on goes yeah with the don't
not fun it takes a real genius not only
to conceive these plays but to pull them
off in a high-pressure situation which
makes the subtle sexiness of 200 IQ
plays irresistible Wow admiralbulldog
give it a freebie and here we go uh-huh
game is on the bait is Lane there's a
small blood patch where Admiral bull in
the trap and it is actually a trap
because they came to check for it then
under stun big guy that I've known
they're gonna bring it down oh boy James
now when the beat is the Swedes they
pull something out of the bag and feet
is gonna go down as well Oh hunter no
one has ever done that no one has ever
done that in the history of dota
after all size doesn't matter
except when it comes to your brain
doesn't have the kit to play with time
is ticking down that wall it's all gonna
rain on it and actually a second one for
your troubles neato gonna be held by
could get rights on the bomb Nicko's
don't wanna go everybody's doubled up
Tamale
[Applause]
okay I like this for the Gladius this is
this is cheap here trying circle around
the Spitfire what interrupts this a
little bit here where are you going
where are you oh this is so not cool
still Ian small so he's waiting here we
can sort of walk out what are you try to
do is I think he's gonna either he's
gonna either switch to Widowmaker this
the merry-go-round cuz that makes me
laugh it drops down the shooting range
completely no guys that was our top ten
for this week now do me a favor go to
the comments section and write us your
own love or maybe hate letters and we'll
give you a heart if we really like it
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]